spider-man homecoming SARS the third
live-action spider-man since 2002 and
that barely even begins to scratch the
surface is how many spider-man have
appeared on screen over the years no cut
on the show spy drama so how do they
stack up here's a look at the major
versions of spider-man from TV and
movies and the actors who played them
ranked from worst to best
70s live-action spider-man it is an
actor Nicholas Hammonds fault that
nobody remembers the short-lived amazing
spider-man TV show from the late 1970s
he just didn't have that much to work
with there were no super villains no
supporting cast from the comics except
Jay jonah Jameson and a single
appearance by Aunt May and Hammond never
looked talked or moved like anything
other than a random guide you'd run into
at Comic Con
spider-man unlimited spider-man
unlimited was basically an effort to
extend the 90s animated series past
sell-by dates i sending spider-man to an
alternate earth voice actor Reno Romano
just did his best impression of
Christopher Daniel Barnes who preceded
him in the role great it's not only my
carting around my worst nightmare its
week the costume derived from the
spider-man 2099 comics is memorable but
it probably would have worked even
better if they just made a spider-man
2099 cartoon 60s animated spider-man
considering spider-man had only existed
for four years when this show started
relatively few viewers had a clear idea
of just what spider-man should be like
Paul Souls as spider-man sounds the way
1960s cartoon viewers expected a
superhero to sound which means he sounds
exactly like Superman I once swore never
to turn my back on anyone and I'm not
starting now
this spider-man is best remembered today
is the star of many animated gifs and
memes and of course for its awesome
theme song
[Music]
spider-man spider-man does whatever a
spider can 1981 animated spider-man the
1981 Spiderman animated series wasn't
bad by any means the animation was solid
for the time and it brought in a lot of
Spider villains from the comics who'd
never gotten TV time before the weirdest
thing about this show is that it was
immediately overshadowed by another
spider-man cartoon spider-man and his
amazing friends which premiered the same
day the two series also used the same
character designs which kind of made
this series feel like a run of
spider-man and his amazing friends in
which he has no friends and talks a
little thudding thanks to the vocal
talents of Ted Schwartz oh no I'm going
to miss my lunch date with Betty the
Electric Company
spider-man's first live-action
appearance interestingly enough was on
The Electric Company a 1970s educational
series that ran on PBS this spider-man
is played by Danny Seagram's didn't talk
but his simple adventures were the
perfect vehicle for teaching kids basic
language and math skills but the
highlight of the show the narration
which was provided by a priest a Morgan
Freeman and he's pounded a rubber gloves
sandwich spider-man the new animated
series two things are distracting about
2003's spider-man the new animated
series the first is the combo to the and
3d animation the second is that every
time Spiderman talks can't help but hear
Neil Patrick Harris this is so not
spandex not that Harris is a bad choice
for spider-man but come on isn't even
more suited for villainy Japanese
spider-man the 1978 Japanese spider-man
live-action TV series has a cult
following in the u.s. even though it's
never been officially released there in
this version spider-man is a motorcycle
driver who gets the spider powers from a
super bracelet from the planet spider
that shows a lot of fun and the actors
do a great job but it just feels wrong
to rank them any higher when they're not
playing the same slider
as everybody else
[Music]
mm spider-man movies in the early days
of 21st century superhero movies Tobey
Maguire got the job done he got in great
physical shape for spider-man
but he still had the softness played
nerdy Peter Parker punch me I bleed
while he never quite seemed like a kid
and the way an origin story spider-man
should he was still young enough to be
believable as his teenager making him a
solid version of the webslinger ultimate
spider-man Disney's first animated
spider-man series after it purchased
marvel some of the production decisions
for ultimate spider-man didn't sit well
with longtime fans especially the
decision to hire Drake Bell of Drake and
Josh the voice of title character you
don't know how that feels
I do actually someone important is taken
from me too but if you look past the bad
buzz Bell is actually a pretty great
animated spider-man and he also comes
through in the darker moments that
require a more emotional Peter Parker
amazing spider-man the biggest problem
with Andrew Garfield is Peter Parker is
that it was already too old for the part
when he starred in The Amazing Spiderman
he never seemed like an awkward teen and
yet the rebooted franchise offered
another origin story set in high school
still slim build looked good in the suit
and his comic timing made him a natural
fit for the rhythms of the characters
constant wisecracks
knock it off
90s animated Spiderman for a lot of
Millennials Christopher Daniel Barnes
was the definitive voice of spider-man
throughout their childhood while this
spider-man is aged a little awkwardly it
was the first TV version of the
character to really draw the comic story
lines in the nuanced way introducing
concepts like the venom suit
The Secret Wars crossover and even
daredevil this series skipped the origin
and began with Peter Parker already in
college within that context Barnes is
perfect in the parts balancing the jokes
and emotional baggage that are both so
central to spider-man
- danger spider-man and his amazing
friends for those a little older Dan
Gilda's an was the Saturday morning
spider-man of choice he voiced the
central hero on spider-man and his
amazing friends from 1981 until 1986 his
spider-man had the lightness that
earlier versions of the character have
been missing while still seeming more
grounded than the goofier Iseman this
cartoon seems pretty silly by today's
standards but this was the first time
spider-man really seemed like spider-man
and that's worth something the
spectacular spider-man spectacular
spider-man was basically the perfect
cider man cartoon and one that ended too
soon it ran for two seasons in 2008 and
2009 and was being considered for a
third when Disney bought Marvel and
reacquired the television rights to
spider-man leaving this Sony produced
series unable to continue voice actor
Josh Keaton played the youthful Spider
Man with the earnestness of a kid trying
to do with that and it really works it's
just a shame there couldn't be more of
it Yahoo excuse me can I come in this
way or do I have to break my own window
I'm an MCU spider-man as the third
live-action Spidey in under a decade Tom
Holland may finally be the perfect
choice he comes across like a young
teenager with a surprising amount of
power and his youthfulness stands out
perfectly in contrast with all the adult
heroes running around the MCU
basically spider-man homecoming
presenting as a nerdy high school
student who might be in way over his
head
and that's exactly what spider-man
should be especially within the context
of a larger Avenger eccentric setter
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]